- Ils sont plus de 2500
justice devant les tribunaux,
qu'ils soient autochtone
non. C'est le cas de Gaétan
Bégin. Dans les années 50, il
à de nombreuses reprises
par le curé de sa isisisse.
GAÉTAN BÉGIN,
victime alléguée
mon enfance. On a détruit
une granararartie de ma vie.
- Aujourd'hui, l'homme de 82 ans
demande au pape François deueues
les victimes québécoises
de l'église catholique,
- La souffrance a assez duré,
pour moi et toutes les victimes.
Me MARC BELLEMARE,
avocat représentant les victimes
la condition des victimes
de prêtres pédophiles passe
sous le radar et que le paFrFrFn
sans avoir été informé.
- Dans une lettre des victimes,
des victimes alléguées et leurs
négliger personne. L'archevêque
de Québec confirme en avoir pr
connaissance.
- Il a dit qu'il allait remettre
la lettre au pape. Je ne sais
pas
dans la pile de documents
qu'il va qu'il va lui donner,
mais c'est certain que
notre interlocuteur,
- Mais les excuses ne doivent
pas venir seules.
Pour les victimes, la guérison
passe aussi par la réparation.
répercussions que des
répercussions financrereres
dans les hôtels et dans les
restaurants. Il faut aussi
auprès des principales personnes
intéressées, s s sont les
victimes de prêtres pédophiles.
- Les avocats accusent
et des congrégations religieuses
québseseses de faire preuve
de mauvaise foi...
Me ALAIN ARSENAULT,imimimimimims
- À ma connaissance, il n'y ajÉe
catholique dans des recours
collectifs.obobobobobobobobobob,
d'allonger les délais devant
les tribunaux et d'aller
à l'encontre de l'intérêt
des victimes. Le pfifififififift
reconnaître leur souffrance.
- Tout ce que le pape dit,
depuis des mois et des années,
ça ne descdededededededededededs
dans les diocèses.
- Gaétan Bégin tente d'obtenir
réparation auprès du diocèsepupt
de tout coeur avec les victimes
des pensionnats autochtones,
mais il ne veut pas être oublié,
Radio-Canada, Québec.